le département de la réunion recrute
dans le cadre de son programme d'appui à
la francophonie dans la zone océan
indien
les directeurs d'alliances françaises
les assistants d'éducation des chargés
de communication des animateurs noise l
océan indien en afrique australe ou en
inde
moi je m consultante aux seychelles
nation en leur direction
la leon sanchez 38 à madagascar je vais
être assistant d'éducation en langue
française aux seychelles et il s'agit
d'un projet de renforcement du français
entendait ni coordination culturelle
pour l'alliance française de port
elizabeth
vous êtes bénéficiaire du rsa socle vous
avez entre 25 et 55 ans vous avez le
niveau bac à bac + 5
c'est une chance aussi de bénéficier de
la mobilité
c'est une réinsertion ou sens propre du
terme pour moi c'est rencontrer nouvelle
culture rencontre un nouveau pays
c'est toujours un enrichissement
personnel envoyez votre cv à coopération
@ cg974 point fr et profiter d'une
expérience de coopération mobilité
département aux côtés des rings